il y aura un groupe et constructif qui
va se créer au sénat et non je ne peux
pas vous le confirmer puisque nous
sommes face à deux possibilités d'abord
le seul objectif c'est de faire vivre
notre volonté nous sommes un certain
nombre de sénateurs à s'être réunis
après les élections volonté de soutenir
le chef de l'état sur les réformes tout
en étant porteur delà de la
préoccupation des territoires que
j'évoquais alors deux solutions soit on
crée un groupe effectivement les
constructive comme ça s'est fait à
l'assemblée soit on crée une sensibilité
une un groupe une amicale à l'intérieur
d'un groupe de la majorité sénatoriale
refonder donc deux hypothèses la seule
question c'est comment être conformes
cette volonté à la fois de permettre les
réformes qu'elle est libre la sq invite
à privilégier vous cassez vous séduit le
plus moi ce que je privilégie c'est de
discuter avec mes collègues nous avons
porté ensemble pour moi notamment la
campagne avec alain juppé et d'assurer
la mise en oeuvre de réformes sur le
travail
le volontarisme européen la réforme dans
le domaine de l'éducation qui était
aussi dans le projet auquel ailleurs
edouard philippe a largement participé